los estruendos de los bombardeos rusos
estremecen las calles vacías de Bulevar
en la región de ido
edificios abandonados sirven como
refugio para los Soldados ucranianos del
frente este tan solo en las últimas 24
horas reportaron 27 ataques aéreos
moriak nombre de guerra de este Infante
de Marina está atento a cualquier
incursión terrestre de las fuerzas rusas
al pueblo luchamos por nuestros hijos
por nuestros compatriotas ucranianos Por
nuestra nación porque creo que lo que
Rusia está haciendo ahora es el
genocidio de los ucranianos no tenemos
otra opción que ganar por eso luchamos
hasta el final
tú muy Gloria Ucrania
al interior del puesto de comando los
combates son dirigidos mediante radio
teléfono este soldado interrumpe la
entrevista para dar una orden
este pueblo antes habitado por 14.000
personas Ahora solo cuenta con unos
centenares que eligen quedarse como
Emilia buskaia y su hija que batallan
por conseguir agua y alimentos Emilia no
puede contener las Lágrimas al recordar
a sus familiares muertos en la guerra
Hoy es el noveno día desde que murió mi
hermana
nos sentimos mal no sabemos nada
estoy utilizando agua de lluvia para
lavar los platos y mis manos
bulevard significa regalo de carbón en
ucraniano pero sus habitantes no pueden
hacer uso de él para calentar sus casas
en este gélido invierno la industria ha
sido fuertemente golpeada por la guerra
son varios los meses de combates en
bulevar para Rusia su eventual caída es
estratégica para fortalecer la conexión
terrestre entre los recientes
territorios ucranianos anexados y la
Península de crimea ocupada desde 2014